hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the central question running throughout
the whole of Plato's Republic is what is
justice and early in book 1 there's a
rejection of to inadequate points of
view one put forward by pol Marcus that
has to do with friends and enemies and
isn't particularly thought through and
then a more robust and much more
authoritarian one put forward by through
Simic is echoed by the way in another
dialogue by Cal achlys in the gorgeous
and Socrates rejects that as well and by
book two they want him to say well what
is justice we only really get to see
what justice consists in in book four
after a great deal of development has
taken place in an ideal city that Plato
says can function as a sort of analogy
to the human being so what what consists
in justice in the city will also be
similar or analogous to justice within a
human being or as it's going to turn out
within a human soul and they begin the
sort of unveiling if you'd like to call
it by talking about this this principle
that was acknowledged earlier after what
the the young interlocutors of Socrates
call a tedious prologue so Socrates says
listen and learn if there's anything in
what I say we laid down in the beginning
as a universal requirement when we're
founding our city this I think or some
form of this is justice what is that
it's that each person would perform one
function one thing in the state or the
city for which their nature was best
adapted and so we've got people who are
you know clearly gifted intellectually
and can carry out the functions of
rulership and go through the education
that he's going to sketch out in the
books yet to come
he also you know leaves room for the
spirited the aggressive soldier
protector class and then there's this
vast panoply of everybody else who are
going to be citizens and they engage in
productive activities of one form or
another and there's kind of a hierarchy
set in place and that's going to be
analogous to the soul but the key thing
here is that each person or each part
does their job they do the thing that
not only is assigned to them they do the
thing that they're suited for they use
what lies within the realm of their
talents and even more importantly they
don't interfere in the workings of
others and that's one way to define
injustice is as meddlesome and you know
impeding character of those who are
always getting into everybody else's
business and not handling their own
taking over functions that other people
or in the sole other parts ought to be
doing and there's a really great formula
of this set a little bit later having
and doing what is one's own and what
belongs to oneself this notion of what
is one's own we use the word in English
proper my proper function and it's a
translation here of idiom that which is
appropriate to oneself it's what we also
use for private property and things that
are specific to a particular area or
person or whatever else that we're we're
talking about so each person if you're a
cobbler you cobble away and you might
know a little something about other arts
that are connected to your own but you
don't tell everybody else what to do you
don't get into their business you do
your business well what belongs to
oneself so everybody has their role and
they stick to it and so he says that
this is what is just
he also says a carpenter undertaking to
do the work of a cobbler or all these
other things that would be injurious
that's actually bad this ant that's
interference so what we have here
a conception of justice but this doesn't
get us to where we need to go yet
because we want to know okay what does
justice look like in the soul then you
know how does a person interfere with
themselves so Plato has this tripartite
notion of the soul and which we have a
rational part we have a spirited or
energetic or aggressive another great
translation that I don't see in Plato
but I've seen in other works is the
incandescent part and then we have the
appetite of or desirous part that's
focused primarily on what we typically
call creature comforts pleasures of the
body but also interested in acquiring
wealth and it becomes interested in
acquiring wealth precisely so that it
can purchase the things that it wants it
also tends to want to avoid hardship or
labor or things like that as well so how
does all this fit in with justice he
tells us after going through you know a
lot of derivation of these different
parts of the soul that what we can find
in a human being is this three parts and
justice is going to be in a certain
arrangement or as he's going to say
later on a harmony between them and we
have to think well what is the function
of these parts what does it mean for
each of them to do their job and not to
assert or interfere with the jobs of
others what is the rational part if it's
developed properly what is it supposed
to be doing it judges it makes judgments
about things this is good this is bad
now of course the other parts can judge
as well the spirited part can judge
getting revenge on this person is good
and I have to do it right or that person
wronged me that's bad right the appetite
apart has all sorts of judgments about
good and bad you know eating as much as
you can possibly jam into your belly
that's really good right
the feeling of throwing up afterwards
not so good right
that's bad but then you can you know get
room to put more in don't you you can
see the appetite of parts judgments are
not particularly well founded or well
grounded so the rational part engages in
judgment it also thinks things through
it does a lot more thinking than these
other parts do I mean we talk
analogously about thinking with your
stomach or thinking with your genitals
but it's not a lot of thought that's
going on there right it reasons things
out it's the rational part right and it
also issues commands it tells the other
parts what they ought to be doing in
order for the human being to be to be
good to be doing well now do the other
parts listen well that's really up to
them and that depends on how the
individual has become habituated and
oriented that they're their parts within
their soul are they integrated or in
disharmony with each other that's what
we're gonna get to justice what does the
spirited part supposed to do so the
spirited part is that with which Plato
says we get angry and he talks a good
bit about anger in this section and it's
kind of worth thinking about what he
says here he says that on other on
occasions we can observe when desires
constrain a person contrary to their
reason so when the appetite of part is
fighting with the rational part he the
person reveals himself and is angry with
that within which masters him and as it
were in a faction of two parties the
spirit of such a man becomes an ally of
his reason so in when things are
functioning well and your appetites want
you to do something that you think is
wrong and reason is telling you that
like say you know sleep with somebody
that you're not supposed to sleep with
or at a certain time when you're not
supposed to be doing that or drink or
eat more than you should or you know try
to make a buck in order to enjoy all
sorts of pleasures but do so in tawdry
and disgusting ways the rational part
says no don't do that don't do that
right but the spirit the the appetite of
part is like driving you around
and the spirited part gets angry and
says I don't do this garbage right
what's wrong with you right and
sometimes we have people talking to
themselves in such a way on the other
hand as he says if the the spirited
through through modoch part makes common
cause with the desires against the
reason when reason whispers lo thou must
not then we have a problem right so the
spirited part is kind of in-between and
it can make a decision Who am I going to
line up with because the spirited part
is this part this is the part that can
really get stuff done he also tells us
what about when we think we're wronged
if we believe that we're actually wrong
and we judge our anger and our actions
to be just then we will you know suffer
hunger cold and the like we will you
know that the appetites don't want us to
deal with we will follow through on that
but if if the rational part is able to
tell the spirited part listen I know
you're riled up about this but you're
actually getting things wrong that
person didn't mean to wronged you or
what they did isn't really harming you
the spirited part becomes calm again and
so this is how the spirited part does
its job its job is to protect us and
also to listen to reason so that reason
can tell it what is good and then it
imposes reasons rule upon the appetites
and for Plato this is really important
without the spirited part contributing
the appetite apart is probably not going
to listen to the rational part unless
the person has already become very
temperate right so he tells us that the
spirited part is actually an ally to to
reason and then we have this third
appetite of part how does it do its
proper function well you know the things
that it desires are not bad things in
and of themselves eating is a good thing
we actually should desire to eat if we
don't we're in trouble but we don't need
to desire to eat all the time or
dainty's
and sweets and things like that or
drinking you know more alcohol than is
conducive to say lubricating social
occasions doing things at the wrong time
we get ourselves in all sorts of things
in the appetite apart with sexual desire
and also in the pursuit of wealth people
will do all sorts of bad things that
they no reason tells them is wrong but
they the appetites also make their
bidding and the person follows that so
we need temperance and actually you know
we need temperance in all parts of the
soul as Plato has said in in this and
you can see that there's a close
connection between temperance so fro
sunay and justice de kya right he talks
about there being a harmony between
these three parts and that's exactly the
way that he talked earlier about
temperance so you might say okay well
then how are justice and temperance
really different from each other
are they aren't they simply the same
thing are they the same virtue and the
answer is no because what justice
consists in is this ordering here where
there's rulership taking place and these
two parts are allies against the
appetite of part which is always at risk
of you know growing too strong through
self-indulgence so that takes us beyond
that and that's what allows us as
persons to do this to stick with our own
job to not get involved in other
people's business to give other people
what they deserve and take only what we
ourselves deserve the person as as Plato
says the person who actually has justice
is a unity they are one person as
opposed to the person who is unjust who
is really a discombobulated kind of
person many rather than one so justice
within the soul isn't low
hated just in one section of the soul
it's located in the totality of it and
in this ordering that takes place when
reason tells us what to do and gets
things right and the spirited part helps
to impress that upon the appetites and
the appetites obey when we have that
within our soul we have the virtue of
justice which means that justice is a
rather complex thing and justice
involves the entirety of the human
person
you